several rescue ships with hundreds of
migrants on board are stuck in the
Mediterranean waiting for permission to
dock but Italy's new right-wing
government has hardened its stance on
migration one German ship has docked in
Sicily but many on board have been
refused permission to come on land
after days of uncertainty and weeks at
Sea this German rescue ship reaches land
at last a relief for some of the 179
people on board but not all Italy is
only allowing miners or the second
vulnerable to disembark a move Rescuers
say is illegal
it's not only the 104 unaccompanied
miners but all the people on board need
a place of safety
the by law they have the right to
disembark in a place of safety
Italy's new right-wing government has
toughened its policy toward rescue ships
run by non-governmental organizations
they insist the countries whose flags
are flying on the boats should be the
ones to take them
this ship was granted permission to dock
after Germany and France said they would
receive some of the migrants on board
Italian authorities have not responded
to repeated calls from three other
rescue ships off the coast of Italy
carrying hundreds more people
's they are fighting three to four times
in a day only because we are on this
boat and it's too difficult for us to
stay on this boat anymore we are running
out of food
we have food for the next three days
only
after this we might be requesting some
emergency deliveries
um I believe they are planned for Monday
itself it's a bit tight so we hope
nothing happens as conditions
deteriorate at Sea these protesters are
calling on the Italian government to
open ports and ease suffering on the
Mediterranean
well let's go to the Sicilian dark
hosting the rescue ship Humanity one
from where till home and Hall of the
German NGO SOS Humanity spoke to us
earlier I first asked him how quickly
the ship was able to reach Port after
receiving the green light from Italian
authorities
yeah we were actually already waiting uh
in the borders of Catania due to the
weather conditions which were worsening
the last days we had a thunderstorm
uh in front of Catania or in front of
Sicily and in the whole Mediterranean
Sea uh when we reached instructions to
enter the port of Catania around
midnight this night
we received a poet for Rescue and
assistance operation which is pretty
unusual for us after rescuing people out
of distress in the Mediterranean Sea
usually we receive places of safety for
the survivors on boards where they then
can seek protection and reach safe land
this time it was different
yeah well minors and those in need of
Medical Care have been allowed to
disembark it appearance Italian MP Abu
bakar at sumahoro described it as quote
selective disembarkation now till what I
want to know is who actually made the
decision
um who was allowed off the ship and who
was supposed to stay
so the instruction
report were coming from the maritime
recipe coordination Center in Rome uh
which also then was uh yeah basically
facilitating us to enter the port of
Catania and then we had health
authorities on board who decided uh
who's weak enough who's basically in
urgent medical case and who's not
because as you stated they were only
unaccompanied minors women and children
allowed to leave the vessel and among
the adults which were remaining on our
vessel they were just the weakest the
strongest medical cases were decided to
leave the vessel right now there's still
35 people on board that held hostage on
our vessel not being allowed to
disinfect The Vessel not giving any
access to their human rights
tell us how those people left on board
are coping physically and
psychologically
and then stormed the sun and the wind
cover of Catania Port uh helps a lot but
physically the situation is tense uh it
is enormously frustration
you can feel it on board the people are
really not really sure what's happening
to them they have an uncertain future
they are afraid of being pushed backed
from Italy into internet International
mortise or even to Libya that's their
greatest fear we're trying to inform
them that this for sure will not happen
that we are fighting for the human
rights and fighting for the right for
international protection
thank you till womanhall who's the head
of operations at the German NGO SOS
Humanity who's joining us
um from the port of Catania in Italy